speaking of battlefield one Robbie just
watch a story trailer i watch the story
trailer p watch a story trailer I think
we have differing opinions oh really
from my wall I don't know he sits near
me and I heard his reaction of course
like it was curmudgeon like Oh a six
story trailer we'll think of it I was
into it you liked it um I was into it
because jeez where to start i don't know
i was into it because we've seen the
gameplay for the most part I think we
all know what this games games gonna
look pretty good just based on the beta
alone I feel like um and I was
interested where they were gonna take
this depressing s war uh and how they're
gonna present it and inject like I mean
you know it wasn't like a you know huge
explanation of the plot or anything but
you saw a lot of these conflicting
moments with like do I shoot do I not
kill you do I do you know and and I
think that's the Battle of you know that
people's opinions of or in general I why
are we fighting and that seems to be a
parent and this also like dices
challenging how do you depict one of the
bloodiest conflicts ever yeah but
there's there's the other side of the
coin where yes there is that people
thing where people are like oh man with
this war what are we doing by the other
hand though this guy like we will go
into battle and if one out of every
thousand buses remember to imagine the
war stories that will be told for ages
to come I've conflicting module I have
very conflicting emotions because the
first half seems like they're going for
a more personal level maybe how it's
gonna affect them and then there's a
there's a part in the middle where the
music dies down and it starts getting
grim I'm like oh this is awesome like
it's these people coming into war like
everybody's romanticizing it they're
like we're gonna like storm no man's
land we're getting across and then I
thought I was gonna cut debt back to
like the grisly aspects of it that [ __ ]
that like you don't want to see that I
was hoping guys would put in but then it
just cut right back to that like that
speech eaters time it's like a if we
fight like if we push we can win or
something like a like a locker room
speech before a world war one battle
yeah like the game looks great it looks
better in this trailer than it does in
motion and that's saying a lot because
in motion it looks fantastic but in
terms of the story I'm getting from it I
just don't feel like I'm gonna there's
enough for me to really feel confident
about it
because these are these are such small
snippets that they're providing us sure
I do like that this trailer like I don't
know if it's that they're actually gonna
follow through but the trailer kind of
hints it a character-driven campaign
which like in the past battlefields have
pretty much spent like that macho
military one dude jargon stuff one dude
verse all so this one is what there's
used other five characters there is five
perspectives of the war and I was
actually hoping for aside a perspective
from the Central Powers side may it be
German or Ottoman Empire this apparently
is all allied so having like broken some
sell out the battlefield put this on
their site so I kind of skimmed through
it so like the two British pilots that's
your one perspective that's more or less
a chapter of this single player campaign
you have your tank crew which having
read it it it seems to be almost the
exact same idea of the movie fury I was
gonna say like yeah from the beginning
from the first trailer from e3 I was I
had a vibe of that you know being
stranded in a tank treads out with Shia
LaBeouf it's very much that in that they
talk about in a very brief moment they
said like with the character you that
you are playing or seeing is a newbie
who is being introduced to this rugged
unprofessional Dane crew etc etc and and
he's trying to basically you know build
a team and you have different you know
you have the bromance and the planes
basically these two guys like Tom well
you take me back home like I'll do it I
will hold you yeah Shirley's volleyball
scene yeah very much so and then it goes
as far to Italian perspective and the
Alps their alarms ish kind of place it
seemed to be the moment of when the guys
putting on that heavy armor it's like a
they're calling like a mountaineer
regiment called our DD I guess isn't
like the Italian four sets like a almost
like comparison to Shock Troopers from
like world war two maybe that's where
like flamethrowers coming to player I
think so you that's what you'll see d a
lot of that action and then the last
being and then probably one of the most
depressing moments in the war is uh
Gallipoli yeah yeah and so you you
participate in that as the
alien runners yeah you are running info
from probably trenches trench yeah a lot
of chaos and you get steps of those I
believe kind of look like landing crafts
you know storming that ottoman empire
loves the entire focus of the movie
Gallipoli with like Mel Gibson it was on
like carriers and like how like just to
get from trench to trench and whatnot
and yeah I was like the failed attempt
for the Australians to kind of end the
war early at least on the Ottoman front
so that's interesting wasn't there a
better one woman they kept showing and
mentioning yes that's the other one uh
and I didn't know this that is very much
they're saying that she is like Lawrence
of Arabia's right-hand woman or man
we're going to call that Frank's but yet
she's there like the whole step away and
they're basically against the Ottoman
Empire has you see a lot of these that's
where the Train behemoths come in with
the heavy artillery I guess you're
you're trying to make a push on that
mm-hmm and obviously that's in like the
desert setting yeah horseback it's like
that it seems like not just like in
terms of the characters but in terms of
their archetypes it's kind of dividing
the character classes up by campaigns
you said there's the guy in the Italian
Alps who's kind of more of the assault
you sounds like the gallipoli messengers
or more of the scout classes almost it
sounds like there are a lot more stealth
probably look behind enemy lines sure
yeah and then there's the Harlem
Hellfighters did you add Rory mention
that I don't know about much about that
but what I do know is so that's five
chapters more or less with missions
being in those and then there's a
unnamed kind of epilogue which has only
handful of missions so I wonder if
that's gonna tie in any or any other
loose threads to the story of the
campaign and then yeah they show the
last shot of the trailer the Harlan
helped hell fighter against like a
German soldier kind of standoff yeah
both hesitating to pull the trigger and
whatnot yeah a lot of people I think
said when they heard they're making this
game there would that be awesome if the
server shutdown at Christmas for the
Christmas truce wouldn't happen but
that'd be really cool but the Harlem
Hellfighters when they first announced
like the collectors edition they said
some of the Harlem Hellfighters was hard
of a DLC yeah sure well they wouldn't
they wouldn't put an epilogue and DLC
what they know but they could put the
epilogue to tease something for DLC
right there's been leaks or is think
someone like cracked open like the the
beta itself and found that there was
like a patch that's it like French patch
I or I don't even know if dice or anyone
that has even said that there will be
like a French DLC down the road huh I
mean I I know they said they're trying
to go to like unlike unexplored
territory for world war one in the terms
of like in my media and entertainment
but I feel like they've got san quintin
scar the multiplayer map which is
already in France like France is like
where some of the bloodiest battles took
place I him as like a team to play on us
playoffs oh gosh is so like an actual
like side okay I'll be cool if there's
like the attack on Paris when they had
to start using taxi cabs to get people
up to the front because the schlieffen
plan is Germans [ __ ] it up they're
supposed to they were supposed to wrap
around Paris come-from-behind they could
have won the war like right then but
then dude got really bold and came down
right at Paris it's uh times one of the
points where we could have completely
lost dang yeah yeah but that just
touching back like that bummed me out a
little bit as a huge fan of like 1942
playing as both sides but that's only
president multi player that's kind of
it's kind of a bummer to me cuz i would
like to see that other perspective
especially you know world war one you
there is a dipper spective there more so
than world war two which is always you
know as we said like a higher light his
eyes as like good versus evil yeah um
but yeah i mean it more or less it the
trailer was very yeah i mean i I just I
got bits of it and I and I and if it
felt pretty cool it looked pretty cool
to release these moments of you know
heavy fog and the forests like that
almost remind me if I could call that
one was the call of duty modern warfare
sniper mission I'll get up yeah all
ghillied up just like I don't know I
just feel like there's gonna be these
moments of that I'm just that made me
excited yeah the the gallipoli Scouts he
may had a grizzled old dude from what
would they showed when I was thinking of
like with a rifle in the Cape I don't
know I'm kind of hoping there are some
measure moments in the campaign not just
all out like charting trenches like
you're doing multiplayer or not just
trenches multiplayer but just charging
like control points and whatnot I'm
interested how they're gonna kind of
trend like transplant the battlefield
formula into a campaign because I in my
opinion they've kind of failed recently
they intentionally yes in that and how
linear they are more or less and they've
been saying they're going to do like
more sandbox area as and make it a more
battlefield campaign of these
that's what their marketing is saying
but I hope they do to try to translate
that like actual this battlefield you're
playing on into the campaign rather than
just this long line of like follow this
character sure yeah they mentioned a few
scenarios and like their release today
the press release were you know one was
like you know you come across a German
tank you can either destroy it or you
can Hotwire it you know and use it
against you know X or vice versa like
storming and artillery encampment you
can turn the guns the other way so that
was like okay cool that's exciting yeah
cuz I mean one most frustrating parts of
battlefield 4 or is it three I came for
counting was when you all men is
aircraft kerosene and you brought you
knew you and your buddy or pilots and
you're going up to your like f-18 and
you get in the back and you don't even
fly yeah you just point missiles turn
directions mm-hmm I was playing click I
think I literally stopped playing the
campaign uh yeah because that made me so
upset well that's why I like I said like
just to double down what I'm saying I
hope that they find some way to make it
like a sandbox where you don't have to
be in a plane in this set piece a moment
because that's very like a call of duty
thing I think of I hope they're not just
gonna say you're in a plan for the
entire deist mission shooting shooting
down like enemy planes and dogfights I
hope they say here's your objective go
capture that with these people and then
there'll be a story thing to like kind
of contextualize this if you want to get
a plane go do it they are pilots so I'm
assuming like it's probably gonna be a
behind enemy lines moment or something
when they're like down behind enemy
lines thank you see some of that if he
has the clip where the guy was about to
hit him with like up yeah look like a
way to call it like a um was bad look
like a one cricket cricket yeah I saw
that yeah what's go kuh or something
that look like when the guys from the
plane yeah yeah I don't know yeah i
agree through but i think there's gonna
be moments of that yeah it's that's it's
not like the campaign's not like make or
break for battlefield that's not why I
play battlefields but because its world
war one and we it's like very on
exploring games and like you know in
literature is explored but even in
movies it's kind of like not always
there it's not the it's not like a good
versus evil thing like world war two
it's not like a more recent like her
locker or something a lot of people live
still relate to we're like past I think
the last person that was Vaughn world
war one died recently semi recently in
the grand scheme of things so it's a war
that's very much past but it still was a
very bloody conflict accruals exists
today in war because of how bad this was
and the world exists today because of
effects of like new borders and
everything so I'm interested if they're
gonna maybe not take advantage a
terrible term but like maybe if they can
like utilize that in a meaningful way in
the campaign it's tough man it's wishful
thinking i would say but yeah i guess
we'll see the trailer is kind of
encouraging at the same time kind of not
encouraging don't let me bring you down
I think it looks good I just I just want
to measure our excitement it looks like
it'll be exciting it's a good trailer
right like that it is its exact yeah
it's exciting I mean I'm one of many
people who are pulling this just for the
multi-player but to have a campaign that
is you know enjoyable I'm not expecting
like a history lesson I think we all
kind of knew that coming into this game
like from day one sure I said they said
like in an interview Alex crown the
producer said they're not trying to make
a documentary yeah and I hate saying
that works already makes fun of me for
it but yeah the one that they're not
trying to make a documentary they're not
trying to it's like its historical
fiction for all intents and purposes
they're going to use the setting and
what not to tell their own story and
we'll see how that story goes I'm pretty
sure though the history books did have a
horse with a flamethrower guy and a
minigun guy on top of it i saw was going
into battle yeah I love that yeah
someone said like the joke was like it's
kind of a politically charged joke but
showed like the gif and then someone had
said uh oh but putting women into his
game was too unrealistic out there quote
from like a year ago when they first
released it cool so that's battlefield
one it releases on ps4 xbox one pc on
october 21st so what do you think of the
new trailer let us know what you think
let us know you think about the upcoming
campaign let us know in the comments
below